[Música]
lo neuro está de moda especialmente los
docentes estamos casi que bombardeados
por cursos especializaciones técnicos en
áreas como la neuro educación la neuro
enseñanza en la neuro didáctica el neuro
aprendizaje la neuro pedagogía las
neurociencias educativas lo que
coincidimos en eso y de hecho hemos
estado esperando muchísimo tiempo para
que ese puente entre las neurociencias y
la educación se consolide y para que
podamos empezar a beneficiarnos de ese
inmenso conocimiento acerca del sistema
nervioso poder empezar a acercarnos a
intentar conocer cómo es que ponemos
atención cómo es que percibimos a
nuestro ambiente qué es lo que pasa para
que se forme una memoria cómo es que
aprendemos
sin embargo todavía tenemos muchísimas
preguntas en el área en esta que viene
siendo como una ensalada organizada
entre las neurociencias y la educación
podemos obtener resultados y procesos
maravillosos pero de esta ensalada
tenemos que sacar ingredientes que sin
duda no nos van a ayudar al proceso que
queremos lograr
estos elementos que debemos sacar de la
ensalada entre neurociencias educación
son precisamente los neuro mitos
la primera idea importante de descartar
es que los ambientes enriquecidos
potencian el aprendizaje
precisamente los papás de esteban en el
momento en que les dijeron que en su
hijo necesitaba de intervención temprana
porque había un perfil particular de
desarrollo fueron a buscar las mejores
opciones que era lo que les podía ayudar
para que su hijo aprendiera mejor y para
que aprendiera más esta idea de que los
entornos enriquecidos potencian el
desarrollo ha sido algo así como una
maravilla para el neuromarketing y
encontramos muchos programas muchas
ofertas de metodologías de sistemas que
en teoría garantizan esa potenciación de
la capacidad individual los mapas de
esteban hicieron todo el esfuerzo que
estuvo a sus manos y empezaron a
llevarlo cada seis meses a un lugar en
eeuu donde precisamente les ofrecían la
oportunidad de que por unos días lo
exponían a estas metodologías
de estimulación precoz de estarlo
bombardeando con diferentes estímulos de
hecho les dijeron transcurridos un par
de años que esteban ya estaba manejando
varios idiomas que tenía un conocimiento
matemático bastante complejo que tenía
conocimientos en áreas de arte de música
que también eran muy positivos cuando yo
conocí a esteban aún no había
desarrollado lenguaje verbal de hecho no
tenía un sistema de comunicación
no establecía contacto visual con las
personas o con los objetos y estábamos
empezando a trabajar para que pudiera
seguir instrucciones simples el entender
qué significa tm tome siéntese venga
guárdelo toda esta serie de comandos que
en teoría ya habían sido superados en
muchas ocasiones estos neuro mitos
juegan con las ilusiones de los padres
para hacerles creer que entre más tenga
el niño y que cuando tengamos estos
accesos a los entornos enriquecidos
mejor va a ser su aprendizaje importante
considerar esto es falso
y resulta que estas ideas se basan en
unos experimentos que se ya hace mucho
tiempo realizó un científico y su equipo
llamado big green good en la universidad
de illinois el trabajo con ratas su
interés era poder identificar cuáles de
las características del ambiente cuáles
estímulos favorecían y hacían que las
ratas fueran más inteligentes que
aprendieran mejor tomó un grupito de
ratas y las colocó en lo que venía
siendo algo similar al parque de
diversiones de las ratas ahí tenían
laberintos tenían ruedas para correr
tenían túneles para subir y para bajar
habían muchas otras ratas en el mismo
lugar con las cuales además de compartir
había que competir por la comida
y habían otro grupito de ratas que las
ubicaron en solitario estaba nada más en
la cajita la errática con su alimento y
su agua después de un tiempo empezaron a
sacar a las ratas de allí y les pusieron
a vencer un reto tenían que resolver un
laberinto y poder llegar hasta el final
donde estaba la comida
resulta que las ratas que más rápido
aprendieron el camino para llegar hasta
la comida las ratas que demostraron
tener mejor efectividad en su
aprendizaje fueron precisamente las de
el ambiente enriquecido
de ahí
se vino casi que tergiversando dando
muchas vueltas a este significado y se
extrajo esa idea de que los ambientes
enriquecidos favorecen el aprendizaje
sin embargo esto no era la conclusión a
la que llegó el grupo de investigadores
ellos destacaron que y sabían de
antemano que el ambiente más parecido al
de una rata típica de las que andan por
ahí en la noche es precisamente un
ambiente que tiene lugares para subir
para bajar en donde estoy en competencia
con otros organismos donde me estoy
relacionando con los demás es decir
ellos tenían claro que eso que
denominaron ambientes enriquecidos era
básicamente el ambiente el típico de las
ratas
y lo que sí señalaron con muchísima
claridad es que las que se veían
afectadas eran precisamente las ratas
que habían sido aisladas que existe un
umbral por debajo del cual si excluimos
si segregamos si separamos de la
vivencia de todas esas experiencias que
son usuales en cada momento de la vida
por debajo de ese umbral ahí sí estamos
desaprovechando la oportunidad de
promover ese potencial de desarrollo y
aprendizaje que tenemos todos los seres
humanos
la segunda idea el segundo factor
importante a descartar de este
conocimiento entre neurociencias y
educación es aquella casi premisa que
nos dice que lo que un niño hace vive en
los primeros años es determinante
lo que yo experimento desde mi infancia
va a influir en el ser humano en el que
me voy a convertir
por lo tanto cuanto antes mejor si
tenemos una especie de ventanas de
oportunidad de periodos críticos que se
abren y se cierran y es en ese momento
justo cuando podemos aprender y cuando
podemos desarrollar destrezas porque
nuestro cerebro está plástico en ese
momento y ya después eso va a disminuir
caramba tenemos que correr eso fue lo
que hicieron los mapas de carla y ese
fue el tipo de rebote que empezó a
experimentar en el entorno educativo
había esa perspectiva de periodos
críticos de ventana de oportunidad a las
cuales carla no iba llegando al mismo
ritmo que sus compañeros ya de hecho
cuando más o menos tenía seis años no
hablaba
no podía evidenciar de alguna forma lo
que conocía los docentes se empezaron a
decirnos pero será que está chiquita
piensa será que ella puede razonar
porque no tenía lenguaje verbal será que
ella ya llegó a su techo que esa frase
de llegar al techo es como si ya se nos
hubiera acabado el tiempo no hay nada
más que hacer y resulta que carla es una
de esas maravillosas personas que nos
vienen ayudando a derribar ideas
preconcebidas de chocar la empezó a
hablar a los diez años cualquier
científico o cualquier terapeuta del
lenguaje cualquier persona cualquier
persona que investiga acerca del proceso
de desarrollo humano diría ya a los diez
años empezar a hablar a desarrollar
lenguaje oral
muy poco probable carla lo hizo
carla nos demuestra precisamente que
esta idea de qué
lo que sucede al principio va a
determinar toda nuestra vida de qué tal
vez se nos acabe el tiempo para ciertas
cosas eso también es falso y también ha
sido derivado de una investigación
neurocientífica que realizaron estos dos
científicos newbery wiesel por allá de
1960 en esa década ellos trabajaron con
gatitos estaban muy interesados en saber
cuál era la importancia de los estímulos
para el desarrollo de los gatitos y
particularmente de los estímulos que
entran por la vista para el desarrollo
de la corteza visual de los gatos
resulta que cogieron a unos pobres
gatitos y les taparon los ojos con
diferentes dispositivos
es decir los privaron de estímulos
visuales
un tiempo después les quitaron las
vendas esos dispositivos y empezaron a
tratar de conocer cómo era la activación
de esas zonas occipital es de esas zonas
detrás del cerebro que se encargan de
procesar estímulos visuales y se dieron
cuenta que de hecho había una lesión ya
esas neuronas no se activaban de la
misma manera
surgió entonces la idea de que
dependiendo de esas experiencias
especialmente en los primeros años o
meses de vida nuestro cerebro podría
quedar prefijado algo así como perder
esa posibilidad de seguir aprendiendo
sin embargo ahora sabemos y tenemos
también total seguridad de que la
plasticidad cerebral es un rasgo una
característica inherente propia del
sistema nervioso de todos los seres
humanos que si bien por supuesto cuando
hablamos de aprender por ejemplo un
segundo idioma si lo hacemos en edades
tempranas vamos a tener mayor
probabilidad de tener una mejor fluidez
una mejor pronunciación una entonación
mucho más
parecida a los nativos de ese idioma que
él si lo aprendemos ya estando grandes
pero quien dice que uno como adulto no
puede aprender un segundo un tercer
idioma de hecho
y ciudad nos acompaña a todos durante
toda nuestra vida
y la tercera idea que está de igual
forma muy arraigada en nuestro centro en
nuestros centros educativos en nuestro
sistema educativo es el hecho de que
aprender a leer y escribir es algo
natural es como si nosotros asumiéramos
que tuviéramos un gen o un grupo de
genes que son los que nos permiten leer
y escribir que si tuviéramos algún área
en el cerebro que es la que nos facilita
ese proceso de lectoescritura y cuando
alguien no está logrando aprender a leer
y escribir entonces señalamos ya a ver
aquí hay un problema en el sistema
educativo público si ya los 78 años el
niño no se ha saltado en lectoescritura
empezamos a señalar y empezamos a
explorar a ver qué será lo que está
sucediendo si estamos hablando de un
sistema educativo privado nos vamos
todavía más atrás
así que a los cuatro o cinco años ese
niño ya está inmerso en un proceso de
alfa beta alfabetización
y a veces no nos damos cuenta del daño
que hacemos cuando asumimos estas ideas
como ciertas y aquí quería compartirles
la vivencia que tuve con andrés
andrés un chiquillo quien fue referido a
mi consulta por la docente y por la
psicopedagoga del aula
venía con la referencia avalada por la
dirección y la referencia decía que era
importante profundizar en el perfil de
desarrollo de andrés porque tenía una
letra muy fea y porque todavía no
escribía su nombre con los dos apellidos
como la hacían el resto de sus
compañeros
empezamos a evaluar andrés y
afortunadamente nos dimos cuenta que
todo su perfil de desarrollo concordaba
con el esperable en un niño de 4 años
esa era la referencia de una docente
sobre la preocupación del estudiante de
4 años el asunto fue que hice ya la
devolución a los papás y terminamos el
proceso era más o menos hora de almuerzo
en lo que iba saliendo de la oficina veo
que estaba el señor abrazando a su
esposa y ella estaba llorando muy
afectada yo lo primero que pensé fue
caramba no me entendió me di a entender
mal y me acerqué y le dije pero lo que
hablamos es que su hijo está bien que
andrés tiene un excelente pronóstico que
su perfil concuerda en todo lo esperable
con un niño de cuatro años y lo que me
dijo fue sí
pero es que usted no tiene idea de la
cantidad de castigos de enojos de
consecuencias negativas de gritos que
han habido en mi casa desde que empezó
el ciclo lectivo
y entre eso uno se queda sin palabras
esta idea de que es natural aprender a
leer y escribir también es otro mito
porque de hecho y como decían los
compañeros anteriormente la lectura y la
escritura han sido invenciones humanas
invenciones de sociedades que datan de
hace más de 5.000 años atrás por allá en
la antigua mesopotamia o los chinos
ellos empezaron a crear formas para
hacer visible ese lenguaje verbal sobre
diferentes superficies en piedra en
bambú hasta en los caparazones de las
tortugas iban buscando maneras de hacer
visible el lenguaje después los fenicios
introdujeron las consonantes y ellos
dijeron ok se lee se decodifica de
derecha a izquierda luego vinieron los
griegos y inventaron las vocales y
dijeron ah no esa no va a ser la
direccionalidad en la lectura ahora
vamos a leer de izquierda a derecha
todas esas son decisiones e inventos
arbitrarios de hecho sabemos que en
diferentes culturas no se lee
a derecha sino de arriba a abajo
pero precisamente estamos en un momento
en donde casi todo a nuestro alrededor
está lleno de lectoescritura y pocas
veces somos conscientes de que en
nuestro encéfalo tenemos muchísimas
áreas que deben de activarse y de
hacerlo de forma conjunta para que
podamos leer y escribir y que todas
estas áreas en los niños maduran a
ritmos diferentes aquí la individualidad
es lo usual lo típico lo común
sin duda hay mucho que podríamos
cuestionar y seguirnos preguntando de
esta relación de esta ensalada entre
neurociencias y educación
y uno dice básico como identifico lo que
es un euro mito generalmente lo neuro
mitos tratan de darnos respuestas
contundentes a preguntas que todavía
generalmente consideramos que son muy
complejas uno neuro mito está como muy
revestido de magia de
hasta super superstición
y a veces deberíamos usar un poco de
veríamos como de incluso desmitificar a
nuestro propio cerebro a nuestro propio
sistema nervioso si yo tengo algún
problema o alguna duda con alguna otra
parte del cuerpo voy donde un médico y
espero su diagnóstico si no estoy de
acuerdo con eso que me dicen buscó una
segunda opinión en educación deberíamos
hacer lo mismo si no estamos seguros de
algo busquemos una segunda o una tercera
opinión no nos quedemos con la primera
impresión de algo
busquemos avancemos en ese proceso de
indagar que está fundamentado y que no
porque si bien es cierto tenemos como
decíamos muchísimas preguntas hay un
elemento un factor un ingrediente que sí
debe estar presente en la receta de
nuestro accionar cotidiano y los invito
a introducir este ingrediente
el proceso que llevamos a cabo con todos
nuestros niños y nuestras niñas todos
los seres humanos aprenden
aprovechémoslo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]